السلام ورحمه الله وبركاته ان شاء الله
وكم دا 5 تح ترويح م
‏soils free
cou make sisters ands
asil please make sure either you have it
with you and then know your
bot don't leave you
know and when you the pleas throw them
in the trash take
‏you have time after all done here make
up
be
93e and
where ان شا
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استووا واعتدلوا
سو
الصفوف ريت ذا لاين
ذاب
استو الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
لن تنالوا البر حتى تنفقوا مما
تحبون وما تنفقوا من شيء فان الله به
عليم كل الطعام كان حلا لبني
اسرائيل الا ما حرم اسرائيل
على نفسه من قبل ان تنزل
التوراه قل فاتوا بالتوراه فاتلوها ان
كنتم
صادقين فمن افترى على الله الكذب من بعد
ذلك فاولئك هم
الظالمون قل صدق
الله فاتبعوا مله ابراهيم حنيفا وما كان
من المشركين
ان اول بيت وضع للناس للذي ببكه مباركا
وهدى
للعالمين فيه ايات بينات مقام
ابراهيم ومن دخله كان
امنا ولله على الناس حج البيت من استطاع
اليه
سبيلا ومن كفر فان ان الله غني عن
العالمين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
قل يا اهل الكتاب لم تكفرون بايات الله
والله شهيد على ما
تعملون قل يا اهل الكتاب لم تصدون عن سبيل
الله من امن تبغونها عوجا وانتم شهداء
وما الله بغافل عما
تعملون يا ايها الذين امنوا ان تطيعوا
فريقا من الذين اوتوا الكتاب يردوكم بعد
ايمانكم
كافرين وكيف تكفرون وانتم تتلى عليكم ايات
الله وفيكم رسوله ومن يعتصم بالله قد هدي
الى صراط
مستقيم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا
تموتن الا
وانتم
مسلمون واعتصموا بحبل الله جميعا ولا
تفرقوا واذكروا نعمه الله عليكم اذ كنتم
اعداء
فالف بين قلوبكم فاصبحتم بنعمته
اخوانا وكنتم على شفا
حفره من النار
فانقذكم
منها كذلك يبين الله لكم اياته لعلكم
تهتدون ولتكن منكم
امه يدعون الى الخير ويامرون بالمعروف
وينهون عن
المنكر
واولئك هم
المفلحون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استووا
واعتدلوا الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
ولتكن منكم امه يدعون الى الخير ويامرون
بالمعروف وينهون عن المنكر واولئك هم
المفلحون ولا تكونوا كالذين تفرقوا
واختلفوا من بعد ما جاءهم
البينات واولئك لهم عذاب
عظيم يوم تبيض وجوه وتسود
وجوه فاما الذين اسودت وجوههم اكفرتم بعد
ايمانكم فذوقوا العذاب بما كنتم
تكفرون واما الذين ابيضت وجوههم ففي رحمه
الله هم فيها
خالدون تلك ايات الله نتلوها عليك
بالحق وما الله يريد ظلما
للعالمين ولله ما في السماوات وما في
الارض والى الله ترجع
الامور كنتم خير امه اخرجت
للناس تامرون بالمعروف وتنهون عن المنكر
وتؤمنون
بالله ولو امن اهل الكتاب لكان خيرا لهم
منهم المؤمنون واكثرهم
الفاسقون لن يضروكم الا اذى وان يقاتلوكم
يولوكم الادبار ثم لا
ينصرون ضربت عليهم الذله اينما ثقفوا الا
بحبل من الله وحبل من الناس وباءوا بغضب
من الله واضرب عليهم
المسكنه ذلك بانهم كانوا يكفرون بايات
الله ويقتلون
الانبياء بغير حق ذلك بما عصوا وكانوا
يعتدون ليسوا
سواء من اهل الكتاب امه
قائمه يتلون ايات الله اناء الليل وهم
يسجدون يؤمنون بالله واليوم الاخر ويامرون
بالمعروف وينهون عن المنكر ويسارعون في
الخيرات واولئك من
الصالحين وما يفعلوا من خير فلن يكفروه
والله
عليم
بالمتقين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله ال
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
ان الذين كفروا لن تغني عنهم اموالهم ولا
اولادهم من الله شيئا واولئك اصحاب النار
هم فيها
خالدون مثل ما ينفقون في هذه الحياه
الدنيا كمثل ريح فيها سر اصابت حر قوم
ظلموا
انفسهم فاهلكته
وما ظلمهم الله ولكن
انفسهم
يظلمون يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تتخذوا
بطانه من دونكم لا يالونكم خبالا ودوا ما
عنتم قد بدت البغضاء من افواههم وما تخ في
صدورهم
اكبر قد بينا لكم الايات ان كنتم
تعقلون ها انتم
اء تحبونهم ولا يحبونكم وتؤمنون بالكتاب
كله واذا لقوكم قالوا امنا واذا خلوا عضوا
عليكم الانامل من
الغيظ قل موتوا بغيظكم
ان الله عليم بذات
الصدور ان تمسسكم حسنه تسؤهم وان تصبكم
سيئه يفرحوا بها وان تصبروا وتتقوا لا
يضركم كيدهم شيئا ان الله بما يعملون
محيط واذ غدوت من اهلك تبوء المؤمنين
مقاعد للقتال والله سميع
عليم اذ هم
الطائفتان منكم ان تفشلا والله
وليهما وعلى الله فليتوكل
المؤمنون ولقد نصركم الله ببدر وانتم اذله
فاتقوا الله لعلكم
تشكرون اذ تقول للمؤمنين الن يكفيكم ان
يمدكم ربكم بثلاثه الاف من
الملائكه
منزلين بلى ان تصبروا وتتقوا وياتوكم من
فورهم هذا يمددكم ربكم بخمسه الاف من
الملائكه
مسومين وما جعله الله الا بشرى لكم
ولتطمئن
قلوبكم به وما النصر الا من عند الله
العزيز
الحكيم ليقطع طرفا من الذين كفروا او
يكبتهم فينقلبوا
خائبين ليس لك من الامر شيء او يتوب عليهم
او يعذبهم فانه
ظالمون ولله ما في السماوات وما في الارض
يغفر لمن يشاء ويعذب من
يشاء والله غفور
رحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تاكلوا الربا
اضعافا مضاعفه واتقوا الله لعلكم تفلحون
واتقوا النار التي اعدت
للكافرين واطيعوا الله والرسول لعلكم
ترحمون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ين
امين وسارعوا الى مغفره من ربكم وجنه
عرضها السماوات والارض اعدت
للمتقين الذين ينفقون في
السراء
والضراء والكاظمين الغيظ والعافين عن
الناس والله يحب
المحسنين والذين اذا فعلوا فاحشه او ظلموا
انفسهم ذكروا
الله ذكروا الله فاستغفروا
لذنوبهم ومن يغفر الذنوب الا
الله ولم يصروا على ما فعلوا وهم
يعلمون اولئك جزاء هم جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار خالدين فيها ونعم اجر
العاملين اولئك
جزاؤهم مغفره من ربهم
وجنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين
فيها ونعم اجر
العاملين قد خلت من قبل سنن فسيروا في
الارض فانظروا كيف كان عاقبه
المكذبين هذا بيان للناس وهدى وموعظه
للمتقين ولا تهنوا ولا تحزنوا وانتم
الاعلون ان كنتم
مؤمنين ان يمسسكم قرح فقد مس القوم قرح
مثله وتلك الايام نداولها بين
الناس وليعلم الله الذين امنوا ويتخذ منكم
شهداء والله لا يحب
الظالمين وليمحص الله الذين امنوا ويمحق
الكافرين ام حسبتم ان تدخلوا الجنه ولما
يعلم الله الذين امنوا منكم ويعلم
الصابرين ام حسبتم ان تدخلوا الجنه ولما
يعلم الله الذين جاهدوا منكم ويعلم
الصابرين ولقد كنتم تمنون الموت من قبل ان
تلقوه فقد رايتموه وانتم
تنظرون وما محمد
الا رسول قد خلت من قبله الرسل افان مات
او قتل انقلبتم على
اعقابكم ومن ينقلب على عقبيه فلن يضر الله
شيئا وسيجزي الله
الشاكرين وما كان لنفس ان تموت الا باذن
الله كتابا
مؤجلا ومن يرد ثواب الدنيا نؤته منها ومن
يرد ثواب الاخره نؤته منها وسنجزي
الشاكرين وكاي من نبي قاتل معه ربيون كثير
فما وهنوا لما اصابهم في سبيل الله وما
ضعفوا وما استكانوا والله يحب
الصابرين وما كان قولهم الا ان قالوا ربنا
اغفر لنا ذنوبنا واسرافنا في امرنا وثبت
اقدامنا وانصرنا على القوم
الكافرين فاتاهم الله ثواب الدنيا وحسن
ثواب
الاخره والله يحب
المحسنين يا ايها الذين امنوا ان تطيعوا
الذين كفروا يردوكم على اعقابكم فتنقلبوا
خاسرين بل الله مولاكم وهو خير
الناصرين سنلقي في قلوب الذين كفروا الرعب
بما اشركوا بالله ما لم ينزل به سلطانا
وماواهم النار وبئس مثوى
الظالمين ولقد صدقكم الله وعده اذ تحسونهم
باذنه حتى اذا فشلتم وتنازعتم في الامر
وعصيتم من بعد ما اراكم ما
تحبون منكم من يريد الدنيا ومنكم من يريد
الاخره ثم صرفكم عنهم
ليبتليكم ولقد عفى عنكم والله ذو فضل على
المؤمنين
الله
اكبر سميع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليه ولا
الضالين
امين اذ تصعدون ولا تلوون على احد والرسول
يدعوكم في اخراكم فاثابكم غما بغم لكي لا
تحزنوا على ما فاتكم ولا ما
اصابكم والله خبير بما
تعملون ثم انزل عليكم من بعد الغم امنه
نعاسا يغشى
طائفه منكم
وطائفه قد اهمتهم انفسهم يظنون بالله غير
الحق ظن
الجاهليه يقولون هل لنا من الامر من شيء
قل ان الامر كله
لله يخفون في انفسهم ما لا يبدون لك
يقولون لو كان لنا من الامر شيء ما قتلنا
هاهنا قل لو كنتم في بيوتكم لبرز الذين
كتب عليهم القتل الى
مضاجعهم وليبتلي الله ما في صدوركم وليمحص
ما في قلوبكم والله عليم بذات
الصدور ان الذين تولوا منكم يوم التقى
الجمعان انما استزلهم الشيطان ببعض ما
كسبوا ولقد عفى الله عنهم ان الله غفور
حليم يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تكونوا
كالذين كفروا وقالوا لاخوانهم اذا ضربوا
في الارض او كانوا غزا لو كانوا عندنا ما
ماتوا وما
قتلوا ليجعل الله ذلك حسره في
قلوبهم والله يحيي
ويميت والله بما تعملون
بصير ولئن قتلتم في سبيل لله او متم
لمغفره من الله ورحمه خير مما
يجمعون ولئن قتلتم في سبيل الله او متم
لمغفره لمغفره من الله ورحمه خير مما
يجمعون ولئن متم او قتلتم لالى الله
تحشرون
فبما رحمه من الله لنت لهم ولو كنت فظا
غليظا القلب لانفضوا من حولك فاعف عنهم
واستغفر لهم وشاورهم في الامر فاذا عزمت
فتوكل على
الله ان الله يحب
المتوكلين ان ينصركم الله فلا غالب له وان
يخذلكم فمن ذا الذي ينصركم من بعده وعلى
الله فليتوكل
المؤمنون وما كان لنبي ان
يغل ومن يغلل يات بما غل يوم القيامه ثم
توفى كل نفس ما كسبت وهم لا
يظلمون افمن اتبع رضوان الله الله كمن باء
بسخط من الله وماواه جهنم وبئس
المصير هم درجات عند
الله والله بصير بما
يعملون لقد من الله على المؤمنين اذ بعث
فيهم رسولا من
انفسهم يتلوا عليهم اياته ويزكيهم ويعلمهم
ال الكتاب
والحكمه ويعلمهم الكتاب والحكمه وان كانوا
من قبل لفي ضلال
مبين اولما اصابتكم مصيبه قد اصبتم مثليها
قلتم انا هذا قل هو من عند
انفسكم ان الله على كل شيء قدير
وما اصابكم يوم التقى الجمعان فباذن
الله وليعلم المؤمنين وليعلم الذين نافقوا
وقيل لهم تعالوا قاتلوا في سبيل الله او
ادفعوا قالوا لو نعلم قتالا لاتبعناكم هم
للكفر يومئذ اقرب منهم
للايمان يقولون بافواههم ما ليس في قلوبهم
والله اعلم بما
يكتمون الذين قالوا لاخوانهم وقعدوا لو
اطاعونا ما قتلوا قل فادرؤوا عن انفسكم
الموت ان كنتم
صادقين ولا تحسبن الذين قتلوا في سبيل
الله امواتا بل احياء
عند ربهم
يرزقون فرحين بما اتاهم الله من فضله
ويستبشرون ويستبشرون بالذين لم يلحقوا بهم
من خلفهم الا خوف عليهم ولا هم
يحزنون يستبشرون
بنعمه من الله وفضل وان الله لا يضيع اجر
المؤمنين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
بسم
الله بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله
وصح ومن تب باحسان الى يوم
الدين اما
[Silence]
بعد عن حديث رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الدعاء العباده
الله سبحانه
وتالى اللهانه وفر وقال ربكم ادعوني استجب
لكم days
القره الله
سهال اني قريب اجيب دوهي اذا
[Silence]
‏us
are even a
small c out par to att for theer change
and of the parents know the cry between
hungry cry and cry for need for di ch
الله سبحانه
وتالى حث رول
الله
هو حديث
دعاده حث
عليه الصلاه والسلام حديث ث دعص حتى يفت
[Silence]
‏are
الله
‏house
[Silence]
‏things
‏per حث صل الل اغفر اللمن الل هد اللهم
ارزقني اللهم اجبرني الل ارفعني
[Silence]
الل افر
اللد
اجبرن الل دعا
[Silence]
الذك منن ربتنا في الدن حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا ع الن وقنا عذاب القبر وقنا
عذاب جهنم وقنا شر فتنه المحيا الممات
وقنا شر فتنه المسيح الدجال ربنا تقبل منا
انك انت السميع العليم وتب علينا يا م
تواب الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك ارحم الرحمين اللهم
امين اللهم امين اللهم
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدل استو سو الصف سد
الخلل الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
الين
امين الذين استجابوا لله والرسول من بعد
ما اصابهم القرح للذين احسنوا منهم واتقوا
اجر
عظيم الذين قال لهم الناس ان الناس قد
جمعوا لكم فاخشوهم
فزادهم
ايمانا وقالوا حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل
فانقلبوا بنعمه من الله وفضل لم يمسسهم
سوء واتبعوا رضوان الله والله ذو فضل
عظيم
انما ذلكم الشيطان يخوف
اولياءه فلا
تخافوهم فلا تخافوهم وخافون ان
كنتم
مؤمنين ولا يحزنك الذين يسارعون في الكفر
انهم لن يضروا الله
شيئا يريد الله الا يجعل لهم حظا في في
الاخره ولهم عذاب عظيم ان الذين اشتروا
الكفر بالايمان لن يضروا الله
شيئا ولهم عذاب اليم ولا
يحسبن الذين كفروا انما نملي لهم خير
لانفسهم انما نملي له
ليزدادوا
اثما ولهم عذاب
مهين ما كان الله ليذر المؤمنين على ما
انتم
عليه ولاكن
ليجت ما كان الله ليذر المؤمنين على ما
انتم
عليه حتى يميز الخبيث من طيب وما كان الله
ليطلعكم على
الغيب
ولكن الله يجتبي من رسله من
يشاء فامنوا بالله
ورسله وان تؤمنوا
وتتقوا وان تؤمنوا وتتقوا فلكم اجر عظيم
ولا
يحسبن الذين يبخلون بما اتاهم الله من
فضله هو خيرا لهم بل هو شر لهم سيطوقون ما
بخلوا به يوم
القيامه ولله ميراث السماوات والارض والله
بما تعملون
خبير لقد سمع الله قول الذين قالوا ان
الله فقير ونحن
اغنياء سنكتب ما قالوا وقتلهم
الانبياء بغير حق ونقول ذوقوا عذاب
الحريق ذلك بما قدمت ايديكم وان الله ليس
بظلام
للعبيد الذين قالوا ان الله عهد الينا الا
نؤمن
لرسول الا نؤمن لرسول حتى ياتينا
بقربان تاكله
النار قل قد
جاءكم رسل
من قبلي بالبينات وبالذي
قلتم فلم
قتلتموهم ان كنتم
صادقين فان كذبوك فقد كذبت كذبت رسل من
قبلك فان كذبوك فقد كذب رسل من قبلك
جاءوا
بالبينات والزبر والكتاب
المنير كل نفس
ذائقه
الموت
وانما توفون اجوركم يوم
القيامه فمن زحزح عن النار وادخل الجنه
فقد
فاز وما الحياه الدنيا الا متاع
الغرور الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضال
ضالين
امين
لتبلون في اموالكم
وانفسكم ولتسمعن
من الذين اوتوا الكتاب من قبلكم ومن الذين
اشركوا اذا
كثيرا وان تصبروا وتتقوا فان ذلك من عزم
الامور واذ اخذ الله ميثاق الذين اوتوا
الكتاب
لتبيننه
للناس ولا
تكتمونه فنبذوه
وراء ظهورهم واشتروا به ثمنا قليلا فبئس
ما
يشترون
يغرنك تقلب الذي ولا
تحسبن الذين يفرحون بما اتوا ويحبون ان
يحمدوا لا
يحمدوا بما لم
يفعلوا فلا
تحسبنهم بم فازه من الع عذاب ولهم عذاب
اليم ولله ملك السماوات والارض والله على
كل شيء
قدير ان في خلق السماوات والارض واختلاف
الليل
والنهار
لايات لايات لاولي
الالباب الذين يذكرون الله قياما
وقعودا وعلى جنوبهم
ويتفكرون
ويتفكرون في خلق السماوات والارض
ربنا ربنا ما خلقت هذا باطلا سبحانك فقنا
عذاب
النار ربنا انك من تدخل النار فقد
اخزيته وما
للظالمين من
انصار ربنا
اننا سمعنا منادي ان ينادي للايمان ان
امنوا ان امنوا بربكم
فامنا ربنا فاغفر لنا ذنوبنا وكفر عنا
سيئاتنا
وتوفنا مع
الابرار ربنا واتنا ما وعدتنا على رسلك
ولا تخزنا يوم
القيامه انك لا تخلفوا
الميعاد فاستجاب لهم ربهم اني لا اضيع عمل
عامل
منكم فاستجاب لهم ربهم اني لا اضيع عمل
عامل منكم من ذكر او
انثى
بعضكم من بعض فالذين هاجروا واخرجوا من
ديارهم واوذوا
في
سبيلي واوذوا في سبيلي وقاتلوا وقتلوا
لاكفرن عنهم
سيئاتهم ولادخل
نهم
جنات
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار ثوابا من عند
الله
وما والله عنده حسن
الثواب لا
يغرنك تقلب الذين كفروا في
البلاد متاع قليل ثم
ماواهم ثم ماواهم جهنم وبئس
المهاد لكن الذين اتقوا ربهم لهم
جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار نزلا خالدين فيها نزلا من عند
الله وما عند الله خير
للابرار وان من اهل الكتاب لمن يؤمن بالله
وما انزل اليكم وما انز
اليهم خاشعين لله لا يشترون بايات الله
ثمنا
قليلا
اولئك لهم اجرهم عند
ربهم ان الله سريع
الحساب يا ايها الذين امنوا اصبروا
وصابروا رابطوا واتقوا
الله واتقوا الله
لعلكم
تفلحون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم
من نفس
واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث منهما رجالا
كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي
تسالون به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم
رقيبا ولا تاكلوا اموال اليتامى
ولا تاكلوا اموال اليد واتوا اليتامى
اموالهم ولا تتبدلوا الخبيث بالطيب ولا
تاكلوا اموالهم الى
اموالكم
انه كان حوبا
كبيرا وان خفتم الا تقسطوا في اليتامى
فانكحوا
طاب لكم من
النساء مثنى وثلاث
ورباع فان خفتم الا تعدلوا فواحده او ما
ملكت
ايمانكم ذلك ادنى الا
تعولوا واتوا
النساء
صدقاتهن نحله فان طبن لكم عن شيء
منه نفسا فكلوه
هنيئا
مريئا ولا تؤتوا
السفهاء اموالكم التي جعل الله لكم قياما
وارزقوهم
فيها وارزقوهم فيها واكسوهم وقولوا لهم
قولا
معروفا وابتلوا اليتامى حتى اذا بلغوا
النكاح فان انستم منهم رشدا فادفعوا اليهم
اموالهم ولا تاكلوها اسرافا وبدارا ان
يكبروا ومن كان غنيا فليستعفف
ومن كان فقيرا فلياكل
بالمعروف فاذا دفعتم اليهم اموالهم
فاشهدوا
عليهم وكفى بالله
حسيبا للرجال نصيب مما ترك الوالدان
والاقربون
وللنساء
نصيب مما ترك الوالدان
والاقربون مما قل منه او كثر نصيبا مفروضا
واذا حضر القسمه اولوا القربى واليتامى
والمساكين
فارزقوهم منه وقولوا لهم قولا
معروفا ول يخشى الذين لو تركوا من خلفهم
ذريه ضعافا خافوا عليهم فليتقوا الله
وليقولوا قولا سديدا
يوصيكم الله ان الذين ياكلون اموال
اليتامى ظلما
انما انما ياكلون في بطونهم
نارا
وسيصلون
سعيرا الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يوصيكم الله في اولادكم للذكر مثل حظ
الانثيين فان ك
نساء فوق اثنتين
فلهن ثلثا ما ترك وان كانت واحده فلها
النصف ولابويه لكل واحد منهما السدس مما
ترك ولابويه لكل واحد منهما السدس مما ترك
ان كان له ولد فان لم يكن له ولد وورثه
ابواه فلامه الثلث فان كان له
اخوه
فلامه
السدس من بعد وصيت يوصي بها او
دين
اباؤكم
وابناؤكم لا تدرون ايهم اقرب لكم نفعا
فريضه من الله ان الله كان عليما حكيم
ولكم نصف ما ترك ازواجكم ان لم يكن لهن
ولد فان كان لهن ولد فلكم الربع مما تركن
من بعد وصيه يوصين بها او دين
ولهن الربع مما تركتم ان كان لكم
ولد وله
الربع مما تركتم ان لم يكن لكم ولد فان
كان لكم ولد فلهن الثمن مما
تركتم من بعد
وصيه من بعد
وصيه توصون بها او دين وان كان رجل يورث
كلاله او امراه وله اخ او اخت فلكل واحد
فلكل
واحد منهما
السدس فان كانوا اكثر من ذلك فهم
شركاء في الثلث من بعد وصيه يوصى بها او
دين غير
مضار وصيه من الله الله والله عليم
حليم تلك حدود الله ومن يطع الله ورسوله
يدخله
جنات يدخله
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين
فيها وذلك الفوز العظيم ومن يعصي الله
ورسوله ويتعد حدوده يدخله
نارا يدخله نارا خالدا فيها وله عذاب
اليم وله عذاب مهين واللاتي ياتين الفاحشه
من
نسائكم فاستشهدوا عليهن اربعه
منكم فان شهدوا فامسكوهن في ال بيوت حتى
يتوفاهن الموت او يجعل الله لهن
سبيلا والذان ياتيانها منكم فاذوهما
فان تابا واصلحا فاعرضوا عنهما ان الله
كان توابا
رحيما انما التوبه لله على الذين انما
التوبه على الله للذين يعملون
السوء انما التوبه على الله للذين يعملون
السوء
بجهاله ثم يتوبون من قريب
فاولئك يتوب الله عليهم وكان الله عليما
حكيما وليست التوبه للذين يعمل
السيئات حتى اذا حضر احدهم الموت قال اني
تبت الان ولا الذين يموتون وهم
كفار
اولئك اعتدنا لهم عذابا
اليما يا ايها الذين امنوا لا يحل لكم ان
ترثوا النساء
كرها ولا تعضلوهن
لتذهبوا ببعض ما اتيتموهن
الا الا ان ياتين بفاحشه
مبينه وعاشروهن
بالمعروف فان
كرهتموهن فعسى ان تكرهوا شيئا ويجعل الله
فيه خيرا كثيرا
وان اردتم استبدال زوج مكان زوج واتيتم
احداهن
قنطارا فلا تاخذوا منه شيئا
اتاخذونه بهتانا واثما
مبينا وكيف تاخذونه وقد افضى بعضكم الى
بعض واخذن منكم ميث قا
غليظا ولا تنكحوا ما نكح
اباؤكم من
النساء الا ما قد سلف
انه كان فاحشه
ومقتا
وساء سبيلا
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
شفع
الط
صلوا صلاه مبدعه
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى
فجعله
ثاء احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما
شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى
فيذكر من
يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر
ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا
والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله اكبر
سميع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
[Silence]
امين
للاف
قريش
ايلافهم رحله
الشتاء
والصيف فليعبدوا رب هذا
البيت الذي اطعمهم
من جوع
وامنهم من
خوف الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه اللهب
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
[Silence]
امين قل هو الله
احد الله
الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يك له كفوا
احد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده اللهم ان نشهدك ان انت الله لا اله
الا انت الواحد الاحد الفرض صمد الذ لم
يلد ولم يولد ولم يك
كفوا احد اللهم انت الحق ووعدك الحق
ولقاؤك الحق وجنه الحق وساعه الحق ونار
الحق ونبينا حق ونبينا محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
حق اللهم اهدنا في منن هديت وعافنا في من
عافيت وتولنا في من تول ل وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت وكنا واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت
انك تقضي ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يزل من
واليت ولا يعز من
عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب العفو
فاعفو عنا اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب العفو
فعفونا اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب العفو فعفو
عنا اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين اللهم انصر دينك وكتابك اللهم
انصر نبيك محمد وعبادك الصالحين اللهم زل
شرك
والمشركين ودمر اعداء الدين يا قوي يا
عزيز
اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار ورقاب والدينا
وازواجنا
وذرياتنا
وارحمنا
وابائنا
واخواننا وادخلنا جنه مع
الابرار اللهم يا سامع الصوت ويا سابق
الفوت ويا كاس عن عذام لحما بعد الموت
اغفر لي لجميع الموتى
المسلمين الذين شاهدك بالوحدانيه ونبيك
بالرساله وماتوا على ذلك اللهم اغفر لهم
وارحمهم وعافهم وعفو عنهم واكرم نزلهم
ووسع مدخلهم واغسلهم بالماء ثلج والبرد
ونقيه من الذنوب والخطايا كما ينق الثوب
الابيض من الدن
ومتعنا اللهم
باسماعنا
وابصارنا
وقواتنا ابدا ما احييتنا وجعله الوارث منا
واجعل ثارنا على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من
عادانا ولا تسلط علينا بذنوبنا من لا
يخافك فينا ولا
يرحمنا اللهم اعد المسجد الاقصى الى رحاب
المسلمين اللهم اعد المسجد الاقصى الى
رحاب
المسلمين اللهم اد المسجد الاقصى الى رحاب
المسلمين وارزقنا فيه صلاه قبل الممات لا
اله الا انت سبحانك انا كنا من
الظالمين لا اله الا انت سبحانك انا كنا
من
الظالمين وصلى الله على محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله اكبر
[Silence]
‏s السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله ‏ja